of years since the Fukushima disaster
the devastated nuclear power plant has
transformed into something that more
resembles a water storage site 1.3
million tons of radioactive water that
had been used to cool the melted reactor
cores or rain and groundwater that had
flowed into the buildings has been
accumulating in more than a thousand
containers Japan's government says there
at near capacity after a two-year review
the international atomic energy agency
has endorsed Japan's plan for a
discharge into the Pacific Ocean lasting
30 to 40 years
as a responsible leader of the
International Community I have
repeatedly stated that I will not allow
a discharge that would have a harmful
impact on human health and the
environment of both Japan and the world
the water has been treated to remove
most but not all of the radioactive
contamination tritium a radioactive
isotope of hydrogen is still present but
in quantities the iaea says would be
within safe levels the plan as it has
been proposed and devised is in
conformity
with the agreed International standards
and its application
if the government decides to proceed
with it would have negligible
impact on the environment nonetheless
fukushima's fishing industry fears that
a hard-won recovery since the disaster
will be lost consumers in South Korea
have been buying up sea salt and seaweed
before any discharge begins and China
has issued a series of protests
Japan should suspend the plan to release
the water into the sea carefully
negotiate with the International
Community and jointly explore a
scientific safe transparent handling
method which is agreed by all parties
the iaea says China and South Korea are
among other countries that release
Wastewater containing radionuclides into
the sea but the environmental campaign
group Greenpeace says Japan is taking
the cheapest not the safest option
the tsunami of March 2011 disabled
fukushima's cooling system within
minutes triggering meltdowns in three of
its reactors its consequences are still
far from resolved and are set to stretch
decades on into the future Harry Fawcett
Al Jazeera